I don't know if you saw Joel and score
70 cat had 6 70 yeah Jo has 70 today
5 had 70 so what did KN like tonight
mean in the
NBA I se C had 40 a half I mean the
skill level in this league is insane and
and and actually the coaching the
schemes on offense is insane you seeing
so many different sets being run uh for
Bigs to get threes I mean coaches are
being way more creative to put that
players in in great positions to get
those numbers and you got Shooters all
around the floor you got penetrators I
mean this is a peak of basketball in my
opinion you seeing it with guys doing
Manan come on man I BS we got bigs in
the league getting 70 and 60 making nine
10 threes shooting pullup jump shot I
mean it's insane what we got going
[Music]
on